habitat indigne c'est c'est tout
simplement quand on a des personnes qui
habitent dans des logements qui en
viennent à menacer soit leur santé soit
leur sécurité aujourd'hui on accueille
une délégation du Sénat parce qu'on a un
projet de loi qui est passé à
l'Assemblée cette semaine et la semaine
dernière qui passera au Sénat fin
[Musique]
février ce projet de loi est est
important parce qu'il vise véritablement
à faciliter à accélérer la rénovation la
réhabilitation des des logements
dégradés on sait aujourd'hui à quel
point les procédures sont longues sont
complexes et les élus les élus locaux
sont souvent démunis face à l'arsenal
législatif qui existe d'ors et déjà
aujourd'hui mais qui est extrêmement
lourd aujourd'hui on a des outils qui
nous permettent d'intervenir tout au
bout de la chaîne de la dégradation et
là l'enjeu de ce projet de loi c'est de
pouvoir intervenir quand on est au début
de la chaîne et qu'on constate qu'il y a
une inaction des
copropriétaires notre volonté parce
qu'on a lancé aussi une consultation
auprès des élus c'est de pouvoir avoir
le retour queles sont encore leurs
difficultés quels sont les manques
d'outils dont ils pourrai se voir dotter
pour être plus efficace plus performant
parce que derrière la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne dégradé il y a bien
sûr aussi la lutte contre les marchands
de sommeil et puis il y a aussi la
volonté de redonner de la dignité aux
personnes pour qu'elles puissent vivre
dans des logements
[Musique]
décents